yeah welcome to this video playing
maidenhead from Finland down let's see
maybe we get some sharp line of the two
nights not sure about this loading
symbol I'm not sure what what what what
the computed it there alright so he went
for the c5 line and Knight g4 is a rare
continuation but as I very often see
that players are not prepared for that
at all chanson so what you just what is
just playing is some quite harmless it's
not not a terribly bad for white but it
doesn't promise any edge ok let's see
just castles or do I have something more
interesting which would be six maybe
doesn't really doesn't really eat too
much ok yeah this is very equal up to
Queen D for all 94 f Queen h2 so
probably it I take with the Queen and
you know I can take play night at five
you do that
yeah this is some one one problem with
them the doll king porn openings in
general once in a while we would you get
this total clearance in the center and
it's not so much left to play for okay
Bishop d7 maybe yeah 97 rook c8 the only
thing that you can do in this kind of
position is to calculate precisely and
try to use some some some subtleties to
to get something okay on c6 maybe c60 97
it doesn't have a square where does he
go even to a three-year playing b5
interesting it seems you already went
astray here okay well I can back and mix
the night just to f6 don't don't think
that's a drawback after g4 I take b5 and
ce4 hang seng there's basically two
pieces hanging
yeah and I'd 12 c 3 played too quickly
goes night c7 rook c8 is just no square
on g4 that I can even consider to play
night edge for threatening night at 31
tongue it's not really no escape night a
3 B 5 at them it sits before coming yeah
well even in those simplified positions
you need to be precise and tonight one
to c3 was just too quick i guess to
quickly plate
yeah he's looking for some escape but I
guess there is none I think in this
position actually white could consider
to take play rookie seven something like
that I know he played 93 or b-five was
the plan anyway yeah if he goes gee for
now I'm just taking yeah okay okay he
gets two points this is so this is true
trying to get the beat upon to damage
his pawn structure yeah also also night
a seven I can Joe I can go work be seven
and trap it yeah and then if he goes gee
for I have night h for threatening
Knight f3 with a fork so this is not so
not even a valid counter-attack g4y a
piece am not tripping the light
yeah if 94 on now 1c able to or to h4 I
don't know both both looking good yeah
here it cannot be attacked on d4 it can
play work t1 or something this is this
easier I think Knight f3 yeah check can
take worth check here even check get all
this is real well I can fit it's a
spoiled for choice iam now I can take
that one rookie a doll so it's good
everything's good check
check I wrote these seven ourselves even
a made her or close to that and can take
all the pieces not bad as not night
rosanna bad either yeah just the case of
one move to too quick to quickly play it
yeah I think this one here is actually
debatable if white isn't just better my
night f5 also was one of those quick
moves yeah maybe it is not too bad
important is that I don't do that one
Jack disastrous move otherwise it would
be nice I had planned it this one night
night somewhere here and then maybe here
my 95 yeah I'm a slight trouble there I
mean the compass always merciless it
wants to take the pawn and that's why it
is only slightly better but tough
decision yeah well the same doesn't seem
to help and this is outright outright
bad it seems the best defense computer
gives us nice very nice computer wants
to go here and now play rook to e1
yeah this is nice just um securing the
peace yeah well black isn't comfortable
here I'm a bit better those pieces are
more active the night is not great yet I
have some potential on the queenside but
it's very symmetrical why should she
told ya this way you could could
probably draw alright thanks for
watching